Germany's Defense Minister was a la
fonda line and her British counterpart
Gavin Williamson have kicked off the
Munich Security Conference it's a three
days of high-stakes debate and
closed-door meetings the event is
bringing together an unprecedented
number of international decision-makers
including the largest US delegation ever
a multitude of international
organizations are also represented
including the International Monetary
Fund the World Bank and the UN well the
German defence ministers we said kick
things off emphasizing the importance of
partners cooperation our correspondence
with us here at mocs Koscheck is with us
here in studio and assignment Jung is
over in Munich let's listen first to
what the defense minister German defense
minister had to say about the importance
of NATO and cooperation one's a
powerpuff match our partnership makes it
stronger and it increases our
sovereignty because in our partnership
interests are consistent with our values
well to some the world is a zero-sum
game we see the opportunity for growing
together and reminds a prospering
together in those partnerships this is
why ladies and gentlemen NATO remains
our first choice when it comes to our
security
[Applause]
alright Simon let's come to you first we
heard was off on the line they're saying
NATO remains our first choice and we
heard Gavin Williamson also say NATO is
the bedrock of our security again remind
us why is it so important to reiterate
that commitment it would seem obvious
that NATO is an important part of
security well I think because some have
in recent years begun to question
whether NATO does have the answers of
course in particular President Trump in
Washington has raised doubts he
suggested that NATO is no longer fit for
purpose that it doesn't answer the
challenges he's particularly concerned
of course about what he sees as a
failure by the European allies to pay
their fair share of defence spending he
wants to hold them to their commitment
to increase that to 2% of GDP Germany
for instance is one of many countries
that haven't reached that target but the
German defence minister staying here
again today you know that Germany's on
its way it's getting there
Europe needs to do more she said the
Americans are right to criticize us in
that way but she wanted to make the case
for a much wider vision of what NATO is
about as a defender of values of human
rights of human dignity so she was
really widening the vision of what a
defence community needs to do it doesn't
just need to be about cash capabilities
it needs to be about values and
democracy as well she said max I want to
ask you about what Simon just mentioned
you know we heard was left on the line
talk about the return of competition
between great powers and distinguished
NATO from other alliances that exist in
the world and and talked as Simon said
about values and interests but also
about fairness what was she getting at
from your perspective
well she was obviously contrasting the
NATO treaty
to other alliance that they're currently
being left by China and Russia for
example the Belton rote initiative
that's currently built by China and the
Eurasian Union that Russia
building up and what she was doing she
was contrasting NATO against these two
alliances in the sense that these are
not that NATO is not alliance it's built
on dominance she was saying we're in the
lines of equal partners of equal members
or these alliances he led by Russia and
China and led by a dominant power now
Gavin Williamson has also actually been
speaking about NATO as we said and also
talking about the importance of NATO
despite Britain leaving the EU as we
know in just six weeks time let's listen
to his comments but as we continue to
face threats in an increasingly
dangerous world we know that NATO is the
best guardian for all of our security so
for the sake of our values and friends
we will continue to lead a NATO will
continue to build our alliances with
close friends like Germany will continue
to deliver European security will
continue to step out into the world
protecting our friends defending our
interests standing up for our values
all right so Simon very clear that the
German and British defense ministers are
on message sharing the very same message
here that NATO is key but we have again
heard the call for more joint spending
and acting from EU states there's a very
large in fact the largest US delegation
ever at the Munich Security Conference
there at this weekend we know that these
bilateral talks that happen at the
conference it happened behind closed
doors are also really important what we
see then talks precisely on this issue
with the US where there's been so much
friction
well I think that certainly will happen
it will happen it remains to be seen but
you always get a major a Russian
delegation here in Munich and as you say
the largest ever congressional
delegation from the US this year and
indeed vice president Mike Pence will be
here as well so he'll have an
opportunity to meet his Russian
counterpart Sergei Lavrov they've got a
lot to talk about both countries have
said they're pulling out of the INF
nuclear forces treaty that really is one
of the cornerstones of the sort of
post-war post Cold War security order in
Europe so that is an absolutely massive
focus here what Gavin Williamson was
saying there was again this idea of a
values driven NATO but he had a slightly
different emphasis as well one of his
key messages of course is that Britain
will continue to play a role in European
security even after it leaves the
European Union a lot of people have been
concerned that that might not happen but
he said no will remain a stable partner
we'll do our best and incidentally on
European defence cooperation he said we
welcome that we would like to see new
countries and going forward of course
he's talking about joining together
Germany and France you know they've got
this scheme of a European army for the
future well you know he's saying we like
that a kind of idea because it means
there are more capabilities and NATO can
do more max I want to ask you about this
question of European defence cooperation
this is a refrain we've heard over and
over from the German defense minister
but also from a German leaders many
German leaders that Europe needs to take
its own defence and security into its
own hands we heard this at last year's
Mena security conference as well has
this really materialized have we seen
real progress on that front not per se
progress that we see more of a debate or
distinguishing understanding of what's
different parts of Europe want in that
so what's quite interesting to see in
her speech or sofa laFonda line was
actually explaining that both the United
Kingdom and Germany are taking part in
the NATO enhanced forward presence NATO
mission there was introduced
used after the Ukraine crisis to kind of
put more presence forward in the Baltic
countries and in Poland and both the
United Kingdom and Germany are doing air
patrolling there and we're cellphone
aligned was saying in her speech it's
both the United Kingdom - Jets and the
German euro fighter jets and that
already explains one of the big problems
we're currently having in Europe there's
too much difference in the different
military to capabilities they're not
streamlined that were using different
Jets equipment and that's what's the big
kind of current challenge for European
military alliances to kind of have a
streamlined joint force because so many
different countries are using different
equipment okay so that's one of the
hiccups for European defence of the
issues that we heard assignment just
mentioned because because this is a big
picture conference talking about the
various security challenges in the world
right now what do you think are the most
important that will be discussed this
weekend especially for Germany the host
well what we have heard already from a
German defense that was the fatherland
and what we also would like to hear
probably from the other German speakers
were coming in the upcoming days is how
they're going to keep pushing the
message of promoting multilateralism the
German Chancellor Angela Merkel has said
she wants to kind of talk about that on
their unique he could security
conference in the upcoming days and
we've already heard or sort of
underlined giving a sort of the first
pack of that promoting alliances
promoting multilateralism and giving a
clear statement in the theme of the
Munich Security Conference of
fragmentation in the world that this is
an option how to defend it yes saving
the liberal world order that is very
much a defining this year's conference
okay our correspondents max Coe secure
in studio and Simon Young down on the
floor there in Munich thank you both
we'll talk to you bit later